today we're going to continue in what we
were having a look at with Vector
equations of lines and this is one of
the like this is the big idea that we
kind of left off from last time uh we we
started off with the Cartesian equation
of a line and we thought oh we know what
the Cartesian equation of a line Looks
like in two Dimensions can we just
extend it like we have been doing into
three dimensions and we found it didn't
quite work the way we hoped it gave us a
plane instead of a line and then we
realized as you can see up the top here
if we used vectors in our equation that
was actually kind of a sneaky shortcut
for like every Vector like u and v in
this equation up here
each of these really disguises three
equations right there's an X and A Y and
a z component in the U and there's an X
and A Y and a z component in the v so
what we uh what we sort of concluded was
maybe I'll sort of write it like this
what we've got here is the vector
equation and what it's doing is it's
kind of
um standing in front of three separate
occasions which we call do you do you
remember what it starts with it's uh
sorry what it's called it starts with a
P
Ryan you can turn your mic off if you
want as well
yeah the question was the question was
the vector equation which you can see
here this is a a vector equation for a
line
um it's actually a shorthand and it's
abbreviate it's an abbreviation for
three separate equations but we gave
them names we called them the something
equations and it started with a p weird
word we don't use it very much
um yeah very good thank you Mrs Iles
these are called the parametric
equations and the the parameter within
parametric equations it's this um it's
this variable here Theta sorry Theta
Lambda I'm thinking of theta because the
other example of a parametric equation
we've actually seen before
um is for the unit circle so I didn't
talk about this last time because we had
so many different ideas but I just want
to kind of review it it's a very
important connection to make so you
don't have to draw this but I I find it
helpful so maybe you just want to sketch
yourself a really rough one right
when you think about
um the say any Circle in fact but I'm
just going to use the unit circle as a
simplified example right you can Define
any point on the circumference of the
unit circle with two coordinates and x
and a y right but we know that we can
also Express the X and the Y in terms of
the angle measured from the positive
x-axis right so if that angle is Theta
then the x coordinate is going to be can
you help me remember what's the x
coordinate on the circumference of the
unit circle
yeah very good that's cos Theta and
correspondingly it's sine Theta for the
y coordinate right so on the unit circle
the way we would say this is that Theta
is the parameter Theta is a single
variable that if you give me the Theta I
can tell you what the X and the Y are
right and in the same way if you have a
look at the vector equation of this line
right the Lambda is a single variable
that if if you give me the Lambda I can
give you the X and the Y and the Z by
substituting into each of the parametric
equations so this was kind of where we
left off right when you're looking at
this form we saw the parallel pun
intended with the point sorry this the
slope yeah wait did I say it right the
gradient intercept form of a straight
line Y equals MX plus b though uh
writing it as y equals B plus MX turned
out to be an easier way to think about
it and there's the position Vector which
gets us on the line
and the direction Vector which tells us
which way we're facing okay now because
of that this makes it different to the Y
equals B plus MX because in this setup
there's only one y intercept a line only
has a single y-intercept a straight line
anyway but in three dimensions a line
can have infinitely many position
vectors like you can get onto the line
at any point on the line and then you
can face in any in either direction and
in any quantity right so in fact you can
end up having
scalar multiples of V including negative
scalar multiples of v and they will all
give you the same line so that was
something that we had to watch out for
right
so this is the theory that we introduced
and what I want to do today is just very
briefly work through a couple of
applications of this a couple of ways
that we can use this and you're going to
encounter this you've already
encountered some of it actually in the
exercise we've seen last time and I just
want to explore a few more today
so here's what we can pick up if you
want to make a subheading for uh today
let's have a look at how do we uh
Express the line between two points or
an equation for the line between two
points if I just give you their
coordinates so here's a sample right now
remember we have infinitely many
solutions here but one of the ways that
we can think about this a very standard
way is to think okay well we've got a
somewhere we've got B somewhere and the
coordinates that we've got for A and B
they they tell us where A and B are in
relation to O right so if this is where
my o my origin is I know what this
Vector is in terms of the coordinates of
a and then I also know what this Vector
is in terms of the coordinates of B
right so what I really want
is this Vector here A B
that's going to give me a um think about
it in terms of the language that we just
introduced this a b is that the position
vector or the direction Vector which is
it
right yep that's the direction because
the whole line if I extend it out a b
right it would go like so
so you can see a b is facing in the
direction of the whole line and then
when I think about what will my position
vector be well I I really could choose
either right I could choose OA or I
could choose OB because A and B are both
on the line by definition right
um just because it's a I'm going to use
a first monitron
so here's what we're going to do we're
going to use O A as our position vector
and then what I'm going to do is I'm
going to find a b and make that my
direction vector
by the way you don't have to write this
at the start but I find it I found it
very helpful when I began because I
would mix up my position vector and my
direction vector and then I would feel
really silly when I looked at the
solution and I'm like I got it right I
just switched it around so this is the
way that I'm going to do it and of
course if you wanted you could have made
OB the position Vector you could have
made ba the direction vector and you
still would have gotten the same line
okay
so let's go ahead um I don't really need
to calculate away because it's just you
know there it is right there really I
just have to translate it into the
appropriate form so really I just want
to work out a b yeah
so a b can someone tell me what are they
going to write to start calculating a b
what would be your first line of working
probably I'll probably write a
plus OB and then change it to the
appropriate object or negative array
yeah fantastic I do exactly the same
thing so I know that A to B is the same
as going via like a third stop which you
can literally see on my diagram over
here on the right hand side and so let
me turn my phone down so exactly like
you just said that oh sorry that AO is
the same as take away OA and then OB is
out the front there and so now this
allows me very simply without keeping
too much in my head to write out what's
going on here right because you can see
the components up above so OB I'm just
going to write them down negative two
one and zero and then because I'm
subtracting away I'm going to reverse
all the signs that I had in the a
coordinates so that would give me plus
one
plus 2 minus three you guys okay with
that and by the way I don't know about
you this is this is actually how I write
it I write it in that order I write all
of the parts of B first and then I
follow that with all the parts of a
because that way I find that just easier
to read them all at once and put them
down the column okay
all right so what are we getting here so
if I'm doing my numbers right that's
take away one three negative three all
right so I've got a B now so I want a
line and like we saw before we tend to
write that as r
I'm going to put the position Vector
first and then I'm going to add on
Lambda multiples of the direction Vector
so what was our position Vector again
minus one minus two three yeah fantastic
so I'm just reading that off from the
coordinates of a and then I will add
excuse me Lambda of the vector we just
worked out negative one three
negative three
that's it happy times